Never trust for real. Something is
significant others and family members
have probably learned long ago. I can't
I can't believe you're attempting to
talk in a persuasive way. That's that's
so insane that you're doing that. Wow.
Okay,
the sweeping is crazy. The sweeping is
next level.
I I got it. So I've been compared to
Travis Bickle and Kanye West so far in
the second. I don't I don't I don't know
what you're talking about. I don't know
what you're even talking about.
>> He said he's Jewish. Oh man. Okay. Well,
now there's
>> Back to the drawing board. Back to the
drawing board. Let's see Hutch's uh some
of Hutch's reaction to this. We I don't
know how much we'll get through this to
be honest. If he's just like, you know,
barely responding, it's going to be
painful.
>> They're all under attack. He's tilted.
Oh yeah, 100%.
>> Dude, how do you Where's that read
coming from?
>> They're all tilted. All of them. They're
all tilted. We got they're turning on
each other. We got
>> Okay, well that's just untrue.
>> An irrational chud or chud logic,
whatever the [__] his name is.
He's turning on them and then they're
turning on him and then they're all
acting a bit paranoid and, you know,
it's just a lot. It's a lot.
>> Nobody's paranoid. Well, at least I'm
not paranoid cuz I haven't done
anything.
And it's pretty disgusting.
>> Mhm.
>> It's pretty disgusting.
>> Uh it's I Well, let me let me just think
of what I'm going to say. I'm a very
abrasive person. Okay, I understand not
liking me. I understand having it out
for me. In fact, I I totally get that.
Okay? What I would hope what I would
did hope is that there were some people
that were discerning enough. And there
are, in fairness. I'll give one credit,
one shoutout. Specific shoutout. Styro
No One. This guy hates me. This guy
hates me. He's not an RFC guy. But I but
I see him standing on
>> Um did you see Tactical Templar's tweet
that he tagged you in about Nikandros?
No, I did not look at my
>> Hutch, check it. Hutch, check the
Tactical Templar tweet. Hutch, quick.
Tactical
I was remarkably offline this weekend.
>> Oh, we don't believe you, bro.
>> It was nice. I only spent like 30
minutes being online this weekend.
>> You know, what he obviously should
believe, what I would what I would
assume he believes. Uh total random just
a random shout out like just to cite one
person that I saw being quite quite
discerning about the stuff.
Um But yeah, you don't see it from a lot
of content creators, to be honest. You
really don't. Um so I I I don't know how
I want to really go about explaining
this because there's something I want to
try and convey, but it's it's tricky.
>> Mhm. It's tricky, man.
>> There are some base-level principles in
this kind of content creation in this
sort of I don't want to say sector cuz
that is a specific thing, but this area
of the internet.
>> Okay, hit me with them.
>> The idea that when you participate
online
>> Mhm.
>> as part of a community
>> you are responsible for your actions.
You are not responsible for the actions
of everyone around you or if you post on
a subreddit, you're not responsible for
every discrete instance of harassment.
>> [laughter]
>> Mind you, this is the same guy who has
been He and his community have been
trying to like hit me with a guilt by
association Destiny thing for
>> Is this guy some kind of
No, you said that you were cutting
Destiny off because of a hard moral line
that you drew in the stat during the
sand. Then you lied and said there were
new details that made that a bit more of
a gray area. Then you lied about that
and said you never said it, refused to
ever explain any of it, and then you
attempted to emotionally manipulate me
into not calling you a Destiny orbital
again. That's not guilt by association.
That's you being called out for repeated
dishonesty and not having any moral
standards.
>> like a year a year and a half straight
even though
like I don't cosign everything Destiny
does and I'm not even
>> Can someone send me his initial
disavowal? Someone send me the initial
disavowal, please. We'll go over it
again.
>> and especially close with Destiny, and I
never have been.
>> And on the clip where he sends the gray
area, is Tony listening? Tony will have
this [__] Tony will have this [__]
Tony, if you're listening, type in chat.
Tony is, you know, number one hot
snocker.
Is Kathy dead? No. No. Kathy is just
banned from our community because of the
Luna Box stuff. Maybe one day we can
talk about it, but, you know, at the
moment, it's just too [__] annoying.
It's actually like That is like one of
There's a few things that will piss me
off enough to actually, you know, do
something about something that happened
off platform. And one of those is if I'm
trying to talk to someone and you're
doing insane [__] like reporting.
Now, I as I understand, Kathy said it
was a joke or some [__] It was an act
team YouTube under a video of Luna Box
telling someone to
kill himself in a video game.
But that's just like don't don't even
[__] around with that because no one
wants to talk to someone that's going to
[__] report them as part of the like
conversations, you know what I mean?
Like you're literally you're
knee-capping me when you do that.
>> But they have been trying to guilt by
association me for like death
>> But but I wouldn't, you know, like
usually I I keep the same policies as
most other people, which is I'm not
moderating off-platform behavior because
you you simply cannot. The moment you
accept off-platform behavior as part of
your your rules,
um
you're expected to get involved involved
in like investigating people's DMs,
going around to different servers and
collecting evidence like that. No one
has the [__] time for that. I can't
pay a [__] mod team to filter through
that. It's just not, you know, it's it's
not plausible.
>> Destiny stuff forever. Like I'll post
something on the internet and like
sometimes half the replies will be these
little [__] twerps
uh posting something that Destiny said
like a week before. You're like, "Oh
yeah, what about this?" It was like,
"What the [__] do have to do with that?
I have nothing to do with that. And now
he's singing a different tune I suppose.
>> dude, I saw a bit like earlier. I'm
going to tune in for Destiny for like 2
minutes earlier. I hear him trying like
him say
I'm Can I finally move on from this? Can
I finally move on from this? And then he
just immediately goes back to crying
about [__] and drama channels again. I
dude, you are so tilted. You are so
pissed off.
>> Cuz you're not you're only responsible
for your own
actions.
>> Especially illegal harassment that
happens as a result of the general air
of negativity towards a person. Great
example of this. Some of you may
remember back in the Kephals drama,
Stardust had a big fight with Kephals
that resulted in Kephals screaming
obscenities at Stardust.
>> Don't remember this.
>> us because Stardust stood by Flamenco.
For those you don't know, Flamenco
obviously would [__] around with doxes.
He threatened to send letters to
Xanderhall's mother and he would post on
Kiwi Farms very frequently. Very big KF
poster. And Stardust defended him
firmly. And honestly, that's one of the
few times where I've thought Stardust
won a debate. I thought Stardust did
well there. That was one of the few
times ever where she stood firmly on the
idea that Flamenco isn't responsible for
your swatting. It's not just group
harassment because he's on the forum.
But that's totally been abandoned. That
has totally been abandoned by these
people. And that is a rebuttal?
Rebuttal? Sure Surely Hatch is going to
refute that, right? Seems like quite a
damning point for your friend Stardust,
Hatch. core principle that allows not
just KF to operate and people there to
be able
>> Let him cook a little bit. Let him cook
a little bit. He's working his way up to
it. But he ties it all to Israel.
>> [laughter]
>> And uh in the next like 10 minutes.
>> It is all tied to Israel. It is all tied
to Israel. It is. That's your
motivation. That is your motivation
here. Because you recognized that you're
in an unfortunate position where you
have spent the last 2 years saying [__]
like, "Mommy, your hospital isn't a war
crime."
And you get mocked like [__] crazy
for it. You get a ton of [__] for it. It
gets under your skin like crazy. You
recognize it's a dead-end position to be
in. And so, you use any tactic possible
to crush people who are effectively
calling you out for stuff like that cuz
you've tied your you've tied your
hitched your wagon to Destiny. You've
hitched your wagon to Israel. You've
hitched your wagon to Ethan Klein. And
so, you have to remain firm in that
position. You can't denounce all that
stuff because your audience relies on
Destiny. Um So, you So, you have to
maintain that and you want to smother
out this
uh effective cutting ecosystem that's
getting on your skin. You are You are
literally motivated that your position
on Israel motivates a significant part
of this. And there's literally no way to
deny that. Literally no way to deny
that.
>> Apparently, uh the walls are closing in
and the and the logs are leaking because
uh because Israel. I'm not kidding. Not
a joke.
>> It allows to talk that [__] Um but
allows Destiny's GG to operate. It
allows Leftovers H3 to operate. It
allows H3H3 Productions to operate
because
>> Tree of Ora with a 77-month ogre boy
wears a shock collar when he
masturbates.
Only gets a shock on climax. Ew.
>> There are always negative, illegal,
harassing behaviors that occur as a
result of significant negative attention
online. But not each individual engaging
with the negativity is responsible for
each discrete act of harassment. You are
responsible for harassment that you do,
which hopefully you don't do. Uh
>> Come the [__] on.
That's his whole brand.
>> Oh, yeah. Who do I harass?
Who do I harass? Does make videos about
you? Laughing at you? Who do I harass?
Please, citation. I'd love to hear it.
>> That's his whole That's like him him and
his audience. Their whole brand is just
like harassing people. What is this?
>> Um Yeah, be being mean
equals harassment. Thank you, Hutch. So,
I really do feel like with a lot of the
lawsuit and doxing stuff that's going on
here, I would hope there are a lot more
people that are willing to sort of you
harass Lauren s- aside, you know? I This
isn't really a matter of whether someone
says slurs or whether someone's
right-wing or whether someone's a
communist or someone's a tankie and ML.
Uh, the the
>> Ooh, have we got that? Have we got that?
Yes, here we are. Wait, we need to go to
the other side.
>> I think looking back, I wish I would
have just put that space and just not
talked
>> Hutchinson is trying to rewrite history
and lie about him rebuilding the Destiny
Bridge. The original food shops clip, he
does talk about recovery, but also says
of the Pixie case,
some things have come out and made it
look at made me look at it in a
different light. Okay, let's see.
>> I think looking back, I wish I would
have just put that space and just not
talked about it.
So, that's what that clip was.
That's all that was. And Oger boy is
This is In their minds, this is evidence
that I was teeing up
like rebuilding the bridge. Th- This is
their evidence for that. That I was
angling to try to to try to get back in
Destiny's orbit, which I again, I would
not accept that framing at all. Um,
even if
there are certain things that came out
during the trial that got me to look at
things a little bit differently, there's
still enough public information that led
me to feel uncomfortable with and
disapproving of like the things that
Destiny did. Like besides all this other
like new information that maybe changes
one thing over here, but whatever. Like
this clip is not me saying like, "Oh my
god, I regret throwing him under the bus
and I wish I could go back in his
orbit." This clip was just simply like,
"I wish I wouldn't have dived into the
particular details." That's all that
was. And then he posted another clip.
They keep posting this clip, you guys,
and it's such a [__] nothing burger.
>> Are you ready for an actual spicy
question?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. All right.
Um would you be willing to rebuild the
Bridge of Destiny?
>> Um
I try not to take really absolutist
positions on anything um
except for Aquaman. I think you know, I
think the short answer that to that
would be yeah, but like
it really just depends on a lot of
things like
see
more information come out during this
trial.
Um
I've had people privately reach out and
relay um
The clip cuts off at just like the worst
time, but I go into more detail and the
context was like you guys know I'm a
addict in recovery, right? Like most
people [laughter] know that about me. I
have at various times in my adult life
struggled with moderation and substance
abuse.
When I drink and when I do drugs, I just
want to keep drinking and keep doing
drugs. That's what it is to be an
addict, right? And so then I found the
rooms of recovery and in those rooms,
you hear people talk about very dark
things. In in an NA meeting, you might
hear someone talk about some horrible
thing that they
>> Guys, he's not crawling back to Destiny
for a financial incentive. It's because
of [__] altruistic feeling about
[__] recovery or some stupid [__]
man.
>> They might have abused someone. They
might have like punched their spouse at
some point. They might have stolen from
their parents. Like you hear all kinds
of stories and then in those rooms, like
you learn I think a bit of humility and
you learn a bit of grace. So, if someone
gets on a better path
>> I think that I think that hello everyone
guy has to be trolling. Do you guys hate
food shops for being trans or you just
purely homophobic? I think that must be
a troll mess There's no way that's not a
joke because it's it's simultaneously
chastising you for being transphobic or
bigoted while being transphobic subtly.
So there's literally no way that's not
trolling.
>> path. If someone can make horrible
mistakes and then if they get on a
better path, they can find redemption
and actually try to be a better person,
which is something that I thought that
leftists care about that. Like I thought
that leftists believe in rehabilitative
justice. I thought that leftists believe
that people don't need to be defined by
these mistakes that they make in life.
Isn't that like a core tenant of
leftism? Aren't you supposed to believe
that people can be redeemed? That they
don't need to be defined by the worst
thing they ever did, right?
>> It.
>> That's that's what that clip was and in
the longer version of that clip, I talk
about my experience knowing people that
have admitted to doing horrible things
but are good people that I am glad to
call friends. Like I have I'm friends
with dozens of people that have done
horrible things in their addiction. And
so
>> No, this is a different This is a clip,
Max. This is an old clip.
>> longer version of that clip, I think I
allude to, you know, it really depends
on a lot of things.
>> We're just going over his lies about the
Destiny stuff.
>> It's like
if somebody makes a horrible mistake but
then they take responsibility for their
actions, then I'm not going to
I'm not going to permanently close a
bridge on anyone. I mean that like
almost literally.
Like almost literally. Like if Hasan
woke up one day and decided that he felt
like he was a destructive force in
politics and he started to do like an
honest appraisal of himself and came to
>> So So has Destiny done that? So wait,
where did you see that from Destiny? So
wait, when did you see Destiny do that?
>> conclusion that he wants to be a
glorious lib, I would [__] open a
bridge to that person. That's all that
meant, but these [__] sycophantic,
parasocial psychos heard that me answer
that question in that way and they're
like, "Oh my god, bro. He's like angling
for a new for a new space in Destiny's
orbit." And it's like, "Dude, Yes.
Generally speak-
>> God, and that's what happened, by the
way. That's what happened, by the way.
He did just drift back into orbit.
>> Speaking, I find Destiny to be pretty
radioactive a lot of the times,
especially given the the recent stuff
with like the the Willy Mac stuff.
That's a whole other topic.
>> So, that's our first clip here.
Thank you for the $10 banana 9 with the
chilly the character jumping up in the
air. Thank you. Really appreciate it.
>> [bell]
>> So, let's see the actual clip, guys.
What did he actually say?
>> I I'm in So, I'm in recovery. I go to
like NA meetings and stuff. And so, I
know a lot of people that have made a
lot of mistakes and then got on a better
path and and you know, and these people
are like close friends of mine and they
they made some like really awful
mistakes. So, like
>> Okay.
>> like really bad things,
you know, I put distance there because
we were never really close like that and
it was just kind of like a reputational
hit to be associated with any with any
of that radioactive stuff. And so,
I don't I don't regret that, but I think
maybe I regret in retrospect like
talking about the particulars. Um
>> Right. Right.
>> But, you know,
yeah, I don't I don't really think about
that too much.
>> That was That was what I was actually
going to ask you about next was because
someone in my chat mentioned that you
said you regretted how you handled the
Destiny commentary or how you handled
the Destiny situation at the time. Do
you Have you ever said that before? Can
you confirm?
>> Yeah, I think I I might have said it
today or yesterday. Um but like I was
careful because I didn't want to turn it
into like a content farm.
But, I I just got asked the question so
much because we had collaborated during
the 2024 campaign and
so I was just getting people in my chat
every day like asking about the
situation and so there was no way that I
couldn't like comment on it but
I think like yeah in retrospect it might
have been better just to just to just
plainly say like I'm going to put
distance there and I'm just going to
wait to see like how this plays out and
and that that's a completely defensible
thing but what I did was I started to
you know some of the early information
that started coming out was um pretty
damning on its face like very on its
like on its face and so that was just
something I wanted to like comment on
that um
but you know there have been some things
that have come out I don't pay a lot of
attention to what's going on with the
Pixie stuff but people link me because
they still think that I'm associated
with him and so I've looked at some of
the the you know the transcripts or
whatever I've looked at some of the how
the how the court case has played out
and it's made me look at some of the
stuff in a different light
>> So that's just like a total lie by the
way he's definitely just watched
Destiny's coverage that's literally it
um then we've got his original statement
guys so I think if we go to 24:14
we'll get that
>> Grossman says all right listening to
this reaction I'm going to unsubscribe
the situation being treated like it's
that big of a deal is simply ridiculous
it's unfortunate that it happened it's
not that serious I just want to frame
something to you okay I'm going to
assume that you're a human being that's
capable of empathy
I'm going to assume that you're a human
being that is capable of imagining what
something would feel like and just
proceed from there and I want you to
imagine you wake up one day
and there are nude images of you on the
internet and you know you're never going
to be able to take them down and you had
aspired to to to serve in a somewhat
public role within the framework of like
political engagement as a career
[clears throat]
and on top of being humiliated
>> Yeah the video I was being sent before
the Cardi date really changed my moral
position so it just totally changes
everything oh really the statute hadn't
come into effect yet oh well, that
changes everything.
>> inspired to to to serve in a somewhat
public role within the framework of like
political engagement as a career. And on
top of being humiliated by having your
images out there on the internet for
anyone to see, now you have to consider
dozens of other ways that this could
potentially impact your life. You have
to live with the stress that some crazy
internet person and there's no shortage
of crazy people on the internet. You
have to live with the concern that some
crazy person on the internet is going to
send your nude photos to your friends,
to your family, to your parents, to your
siblings, to your employers, to your
future employers. And so the So, as a
result of a decision that somebody else
made without your consent, that you were
not a party to, you have to now adjust
to that moment psychologically and have
the the fortitude to like go like go
through an experience like that and
still live a functioning life, which
when I ask myself, that
I don't know if I could do it. If I was
humiliated like that, I don't know if
you guys would ever see me again, ever,
on the internet. And then I don't know
what I would do what I don't know what I
would do for like I would I would just
have to disappear. I would just have to
like my whole life would have to change.
So, I think to minimize this situation
and say it's not that big of a deal,
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt
and say that I don't think you really
thought this through. I don't think you
really fully considered how much that
would impact someone's internal life,
their emotional state, their mental
state, which is bad enough, but I don't
think you probably
evaluate how how much it would impact
someone's external life for the rest of
their life. Something like this, people
kill themselves for stuff like this.
Now,
now Destiny didn't do it maliciously,
right? But that doesn't matter because
of his reckless, wildly irresponsible,
wildly impulsive, self-serving behavior,
as a consequence of that, somebody
else's and and now potentially multiple
people's lives are now
possibly forever changed. And so I I'm
just saying, to me, that is a big deal.
So I would encourage you if you're still
in chat, I don't know if you pieced out
already, just think about it. Just Just
think about Just Just imagine. How would
your life change
>> him credit for this for a bit. That's
the worst part. I gave him credit for
this.
>> But just imagine that. I think if you
think about it long enough, I think
you'll start to understand that this is
a This is a big deal. And that what
Destiny did was a profound violation of
somebody else's privacy. And it had
serious consequences.
>> The only thing is that
>> Never trust Twitch, for real. Something
that significant others and family
members have probably learned long ago.
Principles that allow
>> This should be something that unites us
all because Israel's come is cracking
down on free speech. They're coming
after all of us. It may be me today, but
you tomorrow.
>> So are these people like [__]
[__] Why did I say Israel is coming
after our speech? No, I said Destiny,
Dan, and Ethan Klein are willing to use
the tools at their disposal through
connections to big pro-Israel
organizations like the ADL in order to
enforce their will. It's not that Israel
is coming and doing it. It's that Dan is
willing to communicate with people at
the ADL, Ritchie Torres, all these try
and get things taken up to the highest
levels to try to [__] with people's
speech. Meanwhile, Ethan is attempting
to abuse the legal system to do the
same. And Destiny attempts to engage in
like insane TOS breaking harassment to
do the same.
>> Mairo. So you should stick up for me.
>> How this type of content continue should
matter to all of us. They should matter
to all of us. And a key point to this is
that when you're going against that, you
don't win by betraying what you're
fighting for, you know? You do not win
by adopting the tactics of the enemy.
>> [laughter]
>> What the [__]
Oh my god.
>> Wow, don't tell people
>> In his mind
>> I can't believe you're telling I can't
believe you're telling people not to
dox. Okay.
>> And he's on like, you know, he's he's
like deep in the trenches in World War
I, you know? Like he's just out here
every day fighting the good fight.
>> No, we're we're on the internet. No. You
see people say this sort of stuff a lot
of the time. People wanting to take
things further. They they see someone do
something and they think he offered a
single rebuttal for this entire video.
Yeah, that doesn't surprise me remotely,
but I I guess we'll see. I guess we'll
see. Dude, never talk in an expressive
way. I can't believe you're talking in
an expressive way to try and be
persuasive and energizing. I can't I
can't believe you're attempting to talk
in a persuasive way. That's That's so
insane that you're doing that. Wow.
Okay, hutch. Again, what What What does
this read as other than just them
feeling threatened and willing to poison
the well and make it seem like
um ba- basically make it toxic or
impossible to do things that are
effective. That's the goal. That's the
goal. It's blatantly the goal. Anyone
who doesn't see that is a [__]
[__] It's insane, horrible, and they
want to take things further. They they
want to retaliate, but you just you
literally can't. You you literally
can't. You have to maintain the high
ground every time. You cannot allow
yourself to just become whatever it is
you've got a problem with. You can't
stop filing lawsuits because oh, well,
[__] them. [__] them. You can't start
doxing because oh, well, [__] them, they
did it. You can't start lying because
oh, well, [__] them, they do it. Dan's
doing it all the time. You got You can't
just start doing that. But you do need
to hold firm, but you do need to hold
firm, and you do need to be aggressive,
okay? You do need to hold firm, and you
do need to be aggressive, and you need
to stand confidently. You can't that
this [__] almost I don't want to call
it infighting cuz there isn't this broad
group, but the idea for instance here
I'll give you an example. I will
frequently see I'll use myself as an
example. I will frequently see say
something gets posted of me. There will
be a comment from someone who will agree
with me on the core issue being
discussed, and it's a very important
issue, and it should be an important
issue to them. But, you may see a
comment say, "Oh, well, why are you
supporting this guy? He said the N-word
on Kick." I I don't I don't At this
point anyway, I don't I don't do that.
But, you you you know what I mean.
They'll say something like that. They'll
say something like that. Um And that's
got to stop, I think. I'm not saying
that about me, that you've got to stop
saying things about me. I'm saying we
need to stop talking about this stuff.
We need to stop saying that. What do you
mean? Some of these internal
differences. I I an example of someone
else, Bungie, recognizing some of the
uh existential issues that are being
presented to this space right now.
>> He's like, "This isn't about me. I'm not
talking about me." Well, why did you
invoke a specific example involving you?
>> He's taking stands on the right side of
that. I don't care if he supports
Restore. I don't care if he thinks, you
know, black people are
disproportionately low IQ or whatever
the [__] Bungie thinks. Actually, you
don't know what Bungie thinks. Whatever
he thinks, I don't care in the context
of this, right? There's There may be
another time where he's expressing that
where it's worth me fighting on that.
But, when there is a concerted effort to
fracture and smother an effective
ecosystem,
>> They are feeling it, boys and girls.
They are feeling the heat, you guys.
>> That's a problem. That's a That's a real
big problem, and that should be really
kind of, you know, firmly opposed by by
everyone.
>> Yeah, define effective. What do we mean
by that? Yeah.
>> Yeah, firm line.
So, look, let's stop saying Bungie is
Restore. That's all I'm saying. That's
all I'm saying at all. That's all I'm
saying at all. That's all I'm saying at
all. Sorry, guys. I stepped away for 2
seconds. Couldn't imagine Hutch saying
anything valuable, though. So, we'll
call it a wash on the uh copyright
infringement. Um where was I?
>> [clears throat]
>> So, yeah, but Bungie recognizes that, I
think. Where was I? You threw me off.
I've got where I got up to. So, someone
remind me where I was.
>> Relatable. I understand.
>> Oh, yeah.
Smolder and fracture an effective
ecosystem. That was it. That was it.
That's where I was up to.
Um, yeah, it should be a firmly firmly
opposed. And you have to consider as
well sort of the context this is
happening in, right? And why it's being
portrayed the way it is.
>> Okay. Break it down.
>> spun up this narrative that the servers
existed for 2 years. Why is he saying
it's existed for 2 years when it's
actually existed for 10 months?
>> I think it was literally just like just
like a like a simple little accident.
Like a simple
>> [snorts]
>> Dude.
The sweeping is crazy. The sweeping is
next level.
>> a little mistake. Like I I I don't think
it's that deep.
>> Well, just think about that time scale.
What would that encompass? What would
that encompass? It would encompass his
allegations, everything leading up to
it.
>> Guys, Destiny just accidentally made a
tiny, teeny little mistake of you know,
14 I think actually 60. I think it's
actually only 8 months old. I think I
was going off of like British date
format like a [__] Um,
he made a tiny mistake of like 16 months
that perfectly plays into his broader
narrative that he's trying to use to
vindicate himself. Guys, it's a tiny
little mistake of of 16 months and it
just it just perfectly benefits him in a
totally logical way. By by happenstance.
It's just like it just happened out that
way. Just a mistake just benefited him,
I guess.
And everything he did in response,
right? So,
>> I I don't even know what he's alleging
here.
>> So, it is a retroactive What What do you
mean What do you mean you're What I'm
alleging? It Hutch, Destiny shared
sexual videos, images, and recordings
without the consent of the other party
involved and then started doxing people
calling them out for it. And then
started spinning up a narrative about
how I actually have went and working
behind the scenes the whole time to make
this happen and to manufacture
everything and they'd been doxing him
the whole time even though they hadn't
as justification for his actions. I'm
not really alleging anything so much as
just recounting facts that are publicly
verifiable if justification and
attempted vindication narrative to make
it seem as though the only reason anyone
ever even cared about the fact he was
sharing nudes without consent is because
I think it was literally just like
>> a meaningless mistake. It was like you
know 10 months
>> I thought he was about to say that about
the sharing nudes. I was about to go
[__] crazy. Jesus. Okay.
>> instead of a couple years or so.
I don't think it meant anything.
>> Other people were spinning it up in the
background. But we know that's untrue,
don't we guys? Guys, it's a meaningless
mistake that perfectly plays into his
narrative, guys. We know that's untrue
because not only does the timeline make
no sense, but Destiny himself in his Bob
7 manifesto So guys, Ahoy says it was a
tiny little mistake. What's Destiny's
explanation? Destiny has spun up this
narrative that the servers existed for
two years. Why is he saying it's existed
for two years when it's actually existed
for 10 months? Well, just think about
that time scale. What would that
encompass? What would that encompass? It
would encompass the allegations,
everything leading up to them, and
everything he did in response, right? So
it is a retroactive justification
and attempted vindication narrative to
make it seem as though the only reason
anyone ever even cared about the fact he
was sharing nudes without consent is
because other people were spinning up in
the background. But we know that's
untrue, don't we guys? We know that's
untrue because not only does the
timeline make no sense, but Destiny
himself in his Bob 7 manifesto destroyed
Bob 7 for doing exactly that for sharing
nudes of Melina with bows on screen
sharing Discord.
>> So two things here. So it's really funny
because one, he just completely
destroyed his own theory where he said
that
the timeline doesn't make sense. It It
wouldn't make sense. So why would I make
that up? If If I was going to fabricate
a timeline, then why would I Why would I
make that up?
>> Because your audience just believe
anything and you just you just say [__]
without showing proof. So you you never
get contradicted by the evidence. Are
you some kind of [__] [__]
Obviously not you're not a total [__]
cuz you're thinking enough to lie here.
>> Well, I feel like the response is
obvious.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um
People that lie can't keep track of
anything. So I'll tell you why I said
two years if you really want to know.
Here's the actual Here's the actual
reality of the thing, okay?
>> Uh-huh.
>> I love that this works. I love that you
guys were so [__] manic and schizo
posting and scattering and running about
to your little corners and you figure
out when I'm confronting people on
things, I will keep the confrontation
for the thing that I want incredibly
precise and I will fudge or just [__] up
the details on stuff that's not relevant
because you hyper fixate on the
non-relevant things to try to figure out
how much information you think I have.
That's why I said two years.
>> No, we just knew two years was wrong
immediately. Everyone just knew that was
a lie immediately.
No, that doesn't change everyone just
knew that was a lie. We just We just
point out that it's a lie. That That
does nothing to help you.
>> Because when I say two years, now and
this is exactly what happened in every
single server these guys were in, the
whole conversation changed to oh [__]
Destiny's making this up. Destiny hasn't
seen anything. The server's not even two
years old. I think he's just lying about
all of it. I think he's made everything
up. And that's exactly what you [__]
retards did. So if I fudge a detail or
something,
who knows? Maybe I actually don't know
anything. Maybe I'm making it all up. Or
I'm just like fudging a detail because I
know it's not really relevant to
anything and I know that you guys will
hyper fixate on the fudge details to try
to figure out what you think. I do know
so that you can figure out what you can
own to publicly or not, which is exactly
what you all did by the way. That's why
I had That's why Chud hedged every
answer. That's why you guys on Twitter
walked back that Shamu thing until it
was completely and totally indefensible
and fell off a cliff.
>> Chud hedged answers because you were
presenting him incomplete information
and he was trying to make a judgment.
That's why Chud was hedging like you
should when you have incomplete
information. Are you some kind of
[__] [__]
>> And then finally you cut ties, but yeah.
I mean It's not even like that hard to
do. I just like say random [__] and
then you guys freak the [__] out. And
I'll just stay precise on the
accusation, because that's the only
thing that really matters. And if you
>> But, you're not precise on the
accusation. You know you're not precise
on the accusation. You literally cannot
argue the details of any accusation. You
want to zoom out to macro narratives,
where you can't substantiate any of the
individual points. That's just a lie.
>> You think I'm making anything up? Well,
call it out. If you think like If you
think that that Snark Lair server is not
a big deal, or whatever that whatever he
just linked, and you think that I'm
lying about everything, well,
>> You know, hello everyone. I wish I could
just handle everything, to be honest.
Sadly, I'm not, you know, I can't I
can't be in 500 places at once. Is that
It's really the kind of biggest problem
in my life is that everyone isn't just
exactly like me, thinking like me, at
all times. Things would work a lot
better
>> Okay. Publish the server logs. If you're
If you're saying it's basically public,
there's no big streamers in there,
nothing bad happens, and I'm lying about
everything, and it's not even two
seconds, well, just publish the server
logs. No?
>> I I don't care if someone publishes the
server logs. I'm clean. I literally
don't give a [__] Go for it. I don't I
don't have the logs. I don't have the
complete logs with all the deleted
messages. So, there's no point me doing
it, because it would be incomplete, and
you could play with the gray area.
>> Okay, back to this.
>> Destroyed Bob 7 for doing exactly that,
for sharing a nude of Melina with Bows
on a screen share on Discord. And in
that manifesto, Destiny admitted to
doing the same behavior himself in the
past, and having issues with Melina over
it. So, so we know it's total [__]
to pretend that this is just a
manufactured standard, and no one really
cares about.
>> Here's what I'm confused about. They're
like they seem to be upset that that
there's like a drip drip drip strategy
going on here. But, I think one of them
has the full logs, because how else was
Chud Logic able to get like an un-
>> No, so we we don't have a full Well, I
don't have the full logs. Someone might.
I don't I don't have the full logs,
because obviously stuff has been deleted
and moderated, whereas the person that
exported was using better Discord uh
which retains deleted messages. So, if
you post it people could still play with
the gray area.
>> Unredacted version of something that Dan
posted. And it's like, so if they if one
of them has the full logs, why don't
they just post the full logs then? Why
don't they just do that?
Right? Am I overthinking this? The
handle with two euros, thank you so
much. Appreciate it.
>> Because Destiny himself has cared about
it and will claim to care about it in
the past. Even destroyed someone's
online career over it. Deliberately,
actively, actually destroyed someone's
career over it. I'm not going around
getting into private calls with
Destiny's friends recording them and
then chopping it up and trying to spin a
narrative on my stream, am I? That's
what Destiny did with Bob 7. That's what
Destiny did with Bob 7. So, it's all
projection and it's all a retroactive
indication. That's what it's all about.
And then And then So, that's the sort of
drama context here, guys. We drop that
into the broader context.
>> Okay, here we go. This is where it gets
fun.
>> The broader context. What's actually
happening here? It depends how schizo
you want to go with this, really,
doesn't it?
>> And boy, does he go schizo with it.
>> Okay, well, surely there's got to be a
firmer bottle then. You're You're in a
world where I'm going to go full schizo.
I'm going to go full schizo on this.
>> Okay.
>> world where Paramount has merged and
owns the Free Press. Bari Weiss has been
installed as the editor of the Free
Press. The Ellisons own TikTok.
>> You can see where this is going
immediately.
You can see where this is going.
Dude, it's like it's like kind of it's
like almost like beyond like zog kind of
posting.
It's kind of beyond that. Some of you
guys are typing it in the chat. It's
kind of beyond just like just like zog
posting.
>> It feels like Please tell me they were
calling me an anti-Semite.
>> It's kind of beyond that.
>> He's taxi driver minus a taxi. Is that
supposed to be cutting? Or is that
supposed to be awesome? I I can't tell.
>> Some of you guys are typing in in the
chat. It's kind of beyond just like just
like Zog posting. It feels like a little
bit further than that.
>> I know social media seems to be
disproportionately moderating, boosting,
you know, content of a certain
persuasion.
>> [laughter]
>> Guys, is he I don't want to say it. I
don't want to say it. Somebody else said
See, I didn't know this about
Koomin I had no idea. No, I don't mean
dumb. I mean like is he um
>> A Nazi. A Nazi surely.
>> A fan of
Nick Fuentes? Mid-20th century European
history?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, so yeah,
we just straight up went the Nazi route.
Awesome. We straight up went the Nazi
route. That's cool, man. That's cool.
Who's going to tell him?
>> Does Is that what's Is that what's going
on here? Cuz
>> They don't understand the things they
say on Twitter.
>> Uh
just like like listen to this Like
listen to what he says here. Hang on.
>> It depends how skits are you want to go
with this really, doesn't it? You're
You're in a world where
>> Like mind you, I just need to remind you
guys cuz the context of this is a
snarker
>> Mooty walked in chat saying in all caps,
"He's Jewish."
Oh, the the Trib one, famous contribute
guy.
>> Discord channel like logs got leaked.
That's the context. And all of a sudden
he starts talking about Barry
>> No, that's not the only context, is it,
Hutch? I just actually laid out the
other context, which is that there's
huge streamers with an incentive to shut
down
a career incentive and personal
incentive to shut down criticism of
their position on Israel because it is
personally and politically damaging to
them. That's the actual context, isn't
it?
Destiny's using tactics like doxing and
mass reporting to try and do it. And
even Cenk is using vexatious litigation.
And Dan's using the ADL and Richie
Torres.
>> Barry Weiss and Larry Ellison?
>> And the free press, literally Barry
Weiss and the Ellisons.
>> The views of a certain persuasion?
>> Yeah, like like Zionists, like Zionists.
Watch, like Zionists and
I think also I'm sort of you know, I am
sort of looping in some more just
conservative attitudes here as well, I
think. It's sort of what I was going
for, too. Cuz those are definitely I
think those are a little bit favored
right now with a lot of the big tech
companies.
It's schizo how you want to go with
this, really, doesn't it?
>> No, I was saying to you Jimble.
>> You're in a world where I'm going to go
full schizo.
>> Okay, you can't make jokes like that
about people we actually hate. You can
make jokes like that about Gama, you
can't joke about people we hate, okay?
>> Full schizo on this. You you live in a
world where Paramount has merged and
owns the Free Press. Barry Weiss has
been installed
>> Dan wrote for, by the way. Yeah, the
Free Press that Dan published an article
in attacking
a Muslim Senate candidate, I think
Senate, right? Or is he congressional?
I'm not sure. El-Sayed, anyway, uh for
association with Islam. Yeah, the that
Free Press, such.
>> Who is the editor of the Free Press? The
Ellisons own TikTok and all social media
seems to be disproportionately
moderating, boosting, you know, sending
content of a certain persuasion.
>> [laughter]
>> There's There's like a few different
ways that you could read that, I
suppose.
>> That appears to be what's happening
online, overall.
>> It's explicitly stated that the Ellisons
wanted to get TikTok because of all the
anti-Semitism on there.
>> It's a couple of years. And then you see
these content creators that are aligned
with a certain side that are willing to
use every tactic possible to crush the
opposition and they they are benefiting
massively from this industrial force,
this this international industrial force
behind them.
>> Yeah, like like how when Dan writes for
the Free Press or the ADL come in and
put pressure on Twitch to ban Hasan or
Frogan or Danems and institute a rule
against using Zionists as a slur. You
know, I like that, Hutch.
>> Why? It's Stardust is absolutely cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs. Holy smokeish new wept.
>> Thank you for the $5 Jimble. Thank you.
>> All this over like a leaked Discord. He
wasn't lying about going
>> No, no, it's actually about the
half a year long doxing, harassment, and
smearing campaign run by one of your
best buddies. And the the vexatious
litigation that you supported and the
little doxing that comes along with it
that you've given a pass to and the
false DMCA's against subreddits that
you've given a pass to.
>> No, one's getting over them.
>> To try to try and Yeah, it I don't want
to say it, but it is kind of e-Israel.
It's on
>> Where's that clip of Kanye West talking
about the psychiatrist that diagnosed
him bipolar? And he goes
Now, I don't want to say what kind of
person this was.
>> I should have done that. [__] I should
have done that, man. I I don't want to
say
what type of person
is going is going after
my community right now.
It's a Jewish streamer.
>> It's a Jew. Who's got that one clip of
that? Someone help me find that.
>> I should have done that. That's a great
idea.
>> doctor.
Probably like the third funniest Kanye
West clip.
>> online Israel
>> It's up there. They are perfectly they
are perfectly
on that cause and they benefit massively
from the industrial machine that keeps
that running.
So, again,
you can't, you know,
>> Uh, CR We Venture, thank you so much for
$2 benefiting five
>> not left with content ideas like this.
>> For real. Thank you for the £5, Wade.
Truly appreciate it.
>> And demonetized on YouTube. Uh, the
human Steve with $5. I just love how
goobers like this guy and J Stark have
to cover drama slop and harass people
cuz they don't offer anything
entertaining. SMH. The handle that I get
you for two two euros, thank you. Did
you find it?
>> Offered nothing entertaining yet. Did
like 30 minutes of 30 40 minutes of
uninterrupted just me talking about what
I think about stuff and people think it
was like the best content I've done in
months basically. Okay. Okay, Arch.
>> Fun Are you Rick rolling me here?
>> The thing about the red hat that drove
me to a point of exhaustion, which was
misdiagnosed
by a I'm not going to say what race,
what people
uh doctor,
and what hospital, and what media went
to. We know I can't say that.
It was a Jewish doctor.
>> That to try to try and Yeah, it I don't
want to say it, but it is kind of E
Israel. It's online Israel.
>> [laughter]
>> So good. Like, come on.
The parallels are too good.
>> They are perfectly They are perfectly
aligned. I I So, I've been compared to
uh uh Travis Bickle and Kanye West so
far in the segment. And that cause, and
they benefit massively from the
industrial machine that keeps that
running. So, again
>> Tyler Abbott Shinks Shimsks Thanks so
much for $5.
>> I I just picked E Israel out of chat
from Stylo.
>> I'm on a flight and I wake up with a
water bottle next to me like, "Oh,
great. Now I got to be responsible for
this water bottle." Uh From the ashes
with $2, when in doubt, blame the
Steins. Same 3,000-year-old strat.
Stonefist with two months. How Israeli
of them.
>> Again,
you can't, you know, you can't stoop to
that level, but you can't You You have
to be firm. You can't stoop to that
level, but you have to hold a firm line.
You cannot allow people to, you know, do
this divide and conquer [__] and try
and police associations based on some
[__] that happened years ago where that
someone doesn't even do anymore. They
even know evidence I'm doing. And it's
built into a total lie narrative that is
made to vindicate someone on that on
that sex crimes and crush crush the
opposition to their political
perspective, right? Because that's what
it is. Think about
>> Wait, is it about Destiny? Like, is it
about Destiny's court case or is it
about Destiny?
>> have a confluence of personal,
political, and financial interests that
align with getting rid of this
ecosystem. So, they would do anything
possible to do it. Hodge, that's what's
being said.
>> Or is it both? Cuz that's kind of
convenient if it's both. That's like
very efficient. Two birds, one thing.
But, he's kind of jumping back and forth
between like the Steins own the media,
but also
>> They they legit think someone else did
this to him. So, they
>> for exposing his sex crimes or
something.
>> How all this works together, guys? Think
about how all this works together. Why
did Destiny cozy up to the commentary
community all those years ago? Did he do
it because the commentary community is a
totally inconsequential machine for
influencing online opinion, or did he do
it for the opposite reason because
actually the ability to reach young men
who otherwise feel apolitical,
disaffected, or whatever? That's
actually a very very good method of
influencing people's opinions.
>> To be fair, if I recall correctly,
Destiny was kind of talking to anybody.
Isn't that kind of how he's worked for
years?
>> Right.
>> Isn't it the case that Destiny kind of
goes and does his spaces with any random
viewer Andy doing a panel or something
like that? Like, I felt like I just he
just went everywhere.
>> And then those people are often very
active online and willing to spread the
message further. It's probably It's
probably more likely the latter, isn't
it? It's probably more likely the
latter. So, why is it that suddenly,
when that's been torn away, all of a
sudden every tactic is on the table to
try and crush what has replaced it? It
should be pretty obvious to you guys.
It's because people were being too
effective. All comes after the Keemstar
video. The Keemstar gets targeted
because he argued with Don on Twitter.
Leftovers H3 are being targeted because
Ethan was being smeared as a Zionist,
something that he 100% is. I think it
was more of the CPS call.
>> [laughter]
[snorts]
>> Holy [__] I just I I don't expect it
anymore, man. Most of them have stopped
doing this, so I just don't expect it
anymore. Hutch, I don't know how to
explain it.
The stuff I'm talking about was
happening before the CPS call, Hutch. He
filed all the false DMCA's and
registered his content nuke with the
Library of Congress before CPS was
called, Hutch.
>> I got to be honest with you. I think
that that that's the thing that like lit
the fire.
>> Right. Well, so that makes sense
somehow. Surely.
>> kind of makes sense.
>> Why don't you watch the Keemstar video,
Baldy?
>> As soon as you start [__] with
somebody's kids and then involve the
state and then you do that to someone as
spiteful as
>> Keemstar video, Baldy.
>> is at times. You know, that that's going
to that's pretty strong incentive to to
take a big swing back.
>> It's just so what if you just open your
eyes and look at the big picture, it's
so [__] obvious. And I just wish I
just wish there were a few more people
out there, a few more content creators,
a few more people, a few more
communities that that saw it. They kind
of saw through it and recognized what's
on the line here, what's actually on the
line here when you were like
>> So, it's about Ethan being pissed that
he was smeared as a Zionist and Destiny
cover covering up his sex crimes, but
also Israel. That's above it all. Got
its tentacles in everything and I just
wish other people saw it as clearly as I
do.
>> allow this insane litigious freak to try
and shut down anyone calling him a
Zionist.
>> It's all connected.
>> And bang Connect the dots, you [__]
idiots.
in the wake of October 7th is saying
they love Hamas and they deserve to have
their family shot, killed and burned in
front of them. Recognize what's on the
line when you're allowing that to
happen. Recognize what's on the line
when you don't take a firm stand on
that. Recognize how the abandonment of
that principle could come back to [__]
you very quickly. Could come back around
and [__] you very [__] quickly. That
principle that you've relied on for your
entire career that you may have made
tens of videos defending.
>> [laughter]
>> Did Did he just say tens?
>> Yeah, like like tens of prepared videos,
Hutch. Like as in like as in not like
your stream segments, Hutch. Even Even
if it was tens of stream segments, I
think that would still stand to be
honest. I don't
Huh?
Not really.
Kind of. Not not not exactly like that,
but they are you know, I government are
[__] about it. It's mainly the
Palestine action stuff. If you want to
look into that. First I came for Hassan
Again, that's a corny quote, but
absolutely true. But absolutely true.
That should have been your warning sign.
You know, and we're we're way deep into
it now, you know. Hassan said
>> re-re-repurposing
a poem about the Holocaust. Was it a
poem? A saying? Repurposing a poem about
the Holocaust to apply it to the to your
snarker Discord getting leaked.
And then people [__] with you.
Uh flick-flickerless screen with $5
Ethan was already abusing copyright
making legal threats and planning to sue
people about him before CPS. Use your
brain.
>> [snorts]
>> I don't know what you're talking about
there.
>> Totally contradicts his entire theory
here. I don't I don't know what you're
talking about. I don't know what you're
even talking about. High level high
level stuff here, H really, man. Good
stuff, bro. Good stuff. Really really
firing all cylinders today, clearly.
>> Uh Stonefist, did I get you for the tier
one membership? Thank you, buddy.
>> Casey Strongfrog and Dan
>> Bad company with $5. I remember when
Keemstar tried to have a conversation
with you early on in chat, called him
out for the weirdo he is. W community. I
don't even want to unpack that whole
thing again. I I had no idea. People
were warning me and I had I had no idea
just like how unhinged like that this
whole community is. I genuinely had no
idea.
>> It's so crazy. It's so crazy. Site
something, H. Site something actually
bad.
The Sargon lawsuit. Dude, if you weren't
off by that, you're a [__] insane
person. Noah Samson being sued for
saying he backed the gen
>> Uh oh, the banner. I keep forgetting
about that. Yeah, let me figure that
out.
>> Genocide. Now it's patently obvious
what's happening here. Now it's patently
obvious what's happening here. The goal
is to is to litigate criticism of Israel
in a courtroom because people understand
that their position has influence. That
Ethan Klein understands that him being
labeled a this crazy Zionist not just
makes people hate him more, but makes
people hate his country more, his wife
more, all this stuff. And so, he has
both personal and political incentives
to try and shut that down as hard as
[__] possible.
>> What the [__] His country more?
>> Dude, if you weren't off by that, you're
a [__] insane person. Noah Samson
being sued for saying he backed the
genocide. Now it's patently obvious
what's happening here. Now it's patently
obvious what's happening here. The goal
is to is to litigate criticism of Israel
in a courtroom because people understand
that their position has influence. That
Ethan Klein understands
that him being way with this this crazy
Zionist not just makes people hate him
more, but makes people hate his country
more, his wife more, all this stuff. And
so he has both personal and political
incentives to try and shut that down as
hard as [__] possible.
>> I think
I don't know. There's a couple different
possibilities here. It's possible that
Koimon is like like legitimately like
Groper
adjacent. And he genuinely believes this
unhinged rant that he's doing. It's also
possible that all of this is just like
manipulation. Maybe he suspects that
there are Groper adjacent people in his
audience and so he's just appealing to
them with this like nonsense, knowingly
manipulating. I don't really know. It's
like one of those two things. It's
definitely one of those two things.
>> But people just don't clock that. People
just don't clock that. People want to
pretend there's no
there's no underlying motive. So there's
no um
you know, broader narrative motive here.
It's oh it's just [__] flinging. It's
just [__] flinging. Uh no, there is
power centralized in a lot of these
communities around a lot of these
content
>> He said he's Jewish. Oh man. Okay. Well,
Now there's a couple
>> the drawing board. Back to the drawing
board.
>> third layer. Okay. It's possible
>> now actually, you're a self-hating Jew.
How could you be against Israel and
Jewish? By the way, I'm not a I'm not an
anti-Semite. I'm not an anti-Semite.
[laughter]
>> Well, that he [__] hates his parents.
Uh did I throw that in the mix?
>> think creators. There is power and
influence centralized around them and
they have to maintain that.
>> smear such fine young Jewish lad.
>> Thank you for the donation. Hugely
appreciate it. Thanks so much. They have
to maintain that. And they will try and
pretend like they're not doing it for
Israel or for politics or something like
that, but that is always in their mind.
That is always in their mind and it
comes out in their actions. And it comes
out in their actions. It comes out in
their target selection. It comes out in
their actions. It comes out in the
opinions they express. Comes out in what
they cover. And it goes all His core
principles he just hates Destiny lol. I
think Israel seems to be a big part of
his core principles. It's what it looks
like. All the way down. I'm not just
talking about Destiny Ethan whoever
here. I'm talking about Nick, you know?
I'm talking about Augie. I'm talking
about myself. Everyone has an
understanding of how this actually works
really deep down.
Uh Iraqi, this is very low tier stuff,
but he object he's objectively correct
here. Ethan has mainstreamed his
promotion of Israel and brought it to
the forefront of his content, which is
antithetical to the tide of anti-Israel
sentiment sweeping the vast majority of
young people in America. I mean, just
tell
just explain to me how calling what was
happening in Gaza a genocide like by
December 2023,
maybe even So, why can they literally
never get I've already laid out to you
Hutch? The days after October 7th when
people were saying free Palestine, Ethan
said that was equivalent to saying that
you support Hamas. And that if you
support Hamas by saying free Palestine,
perhaps you should have your family
shot, killed, and burned in front of
you. Okay, so it's not just that you
didn't think it was a genocide, okay
Hutch? And also he claimed he did think
it was a genocide for most of the time
despite all of his other positions
contradicting that.
He he could still be seen as a rabid
Zionist.
>> And before that, like how does that fit
into that? I don't know how to make
sense of that. This is the same behavior
that we saw when all of that stuff
popped off when when
Ethan and Hassan had their breakup
because Hassan's community turned on
Ethan like rabidly turned on him. It was
the same kind of thing. They were
accusing Ethan of being this like ultra
rabid Zionist and Ethan was over here uh
saying that um you know
Palestine deserves to be free and Netan
Netanyahu is like a war criminal and
Israel's doing a genocide but he
believes in a two-state solution. And so
to them that's like that's the
equivalent of being an ultra-Zionist and
it's just so insane. It's so [__]
insane. And the other thing too is like
everybody in both chats right now, if
you guys were raised um
with Judaism as a Jewish person, with a
Jewish family, you know, like you guys
probably would have What is What is it
called again, the trip that you take to
Israel? Birthright? You guys probably
would have taken a birthright
citizenship you
birthright trip
>> Yeah, ignore that Ela called the IDF
heroes. Ignore that Ela said that Yov
Galant was a really great guy. Not just
a moderating voice in the war cabinet
because he believed all military
objectives were achieved and that would
just hurt Israel more to keep going. But
but they really great guy. But guys, she
said sorry even though the words sorry
or apology never left her lips in that
entire [__] video.
>> You probably would have uh had a
positive view of Israel growing up, you
know? Is it called Aliyah? Is that what
it's called? And uh what happened with
Ethan is like you
you would you would you would think that
most people would think that that would
be like kind of best case scenario, you
know? Like Seth Rogen talked about his
experience
being raised Jewish and being taught
that uh
>> Dude.
>> you know, never being taught about like
um what the Arab population calls like
the Nakba, you know, like never being
taught about their perspective, you
know? And then you get older and you
discover some things and you You this
and you condemn that. That's like, you
know, pretty good trajectory if you're
someone who who who like really deeply
cares about this issue.
Um, but it's not enough because Ethan
stopped short of, you know, one-state
solution.
>> It's just so delusional, man. It's just
not what happened. Hutch, watch the
Keeler video.
Rebut the Keeler video, then we'll take
you seriously on literally any of this,
[__] It's just not what happened. You
just don't know what happened. You
either don't know or you're lying,
possibly due to learned behaviors from
being an addict.
>> And so, he's just from that point on he
was like an ultra-Zionist. It's so
[__] insane.
>> People will try and pretend, like Chud,
will try and pretend to absolve himself
of any responsibility that there is no
influence from any YouTube video ever,
that watching a Turkey Tom video or
>> Why are you speaking in such
generalities here? This That's complete
BS. Jews are not a people who don't
argue with each other. The argument that
no Jew as a kid heard the Arab side of
the argument is just false. You can't
imagine being raised Jewish and not
being taught about the Pales-
>> That's not what was said. That's just
not what was said.
>> Palestinian perspective? You can't even
imagine that? Really? Are you just Are
you [__] with me? You genuinely can't
imagine that?
>> No, you presented that as either the
default or monolithic experience. The
person is challenging that, saying
that's not necessarily true.
>> I am Jewish, Hutch. It's just BS. So,
your experience as a Jewish person is
like the universal experience? Every
Every kid is indoctrinated in some kind
of way growing up. This is This is not
something that's limited to one religion
or another religion, et cetera, et
cetera. Uh, Hutch, make no mistake. This
guy doesn't give a [__] about Israel.
This is nothing but an appeal to that
crowd to help him. He's nothing but a
snarker. He's not a political person.
Well, I knew that about Kman. I don't
think he's motivated by politics like at
all. Hutch, you are being stun locked.
Okay, yeah, you're a
>> Cuz I I just sort of say [__]
>> I just sort of say [__] True. True. I
just sort of say [__]
>> On, you know, the Charlie Kirk shooting
where he says, "Charlie Kirk was a
little bit controversial." Yeah, I I I
don't nuke my streams for like 2 hours a
day doing Brit poll. I don't have an
entire side channel where I do nothing
but politics. I just don't care,
actually. I just literally don't give a
[__] actually. Sure. Anyway, there's a
trans cult spreading widely across It's
just a bit. It's a bit. It's actually
extended bit. It's like quite a Stewart
Lee-esque bit where I deliberately do
things repeatedly that frustrate the
audience because the as you do it more
and more, it starts to gain a humor and
you're able to you're able to loop it
round thematically and and pre-subs. So
So it's just like it's just like a bit.
It's just like an extended bit. The
internet.
>> Like that Crimes guy guy said. People
want to pretend there's no influence
that has because they want to both
absolve themselves of any responsibility
so they can sleep easy at night when
they know they're betraying their
principles and also so that people are
unable to latch on to something they say
and make a criticism of them that bites.
Because if you say that I have I have no
influence. I have I have no effect, you
you're able to take the wind out of a
lot of criticisms. But that's
>> CRWEEVANGEL with $5. Why don't you try
steel manning him says the same people
who have never steel manned a single
thing from their enemy. It's a good one,
buddy. I didn't see that. Flicker
Flicker Flicker the screen with $5.
November 2024, false DMCA takedowns of
Reddit posts.
>> 7-hour PMQs stream with Hasan Destiny
drama title with Kman or I feel like
I've basically done that before.
>> legal threats against Reddit. January
2025, copyright plan to sue pro-pally
creators. March 2025, CPS. Well, the the
Well,
hold on. The Reddit post, I don't
remember what that was about. Um, but it
obviously escalated. I don't know why
you're fighting me on this one. It
obviously escalated dramatically
after the CPS stuff. But, the CPS stuff
was like not That was not like the first
shot across the bow. Like, it had been
in intense
harassment
>> Right.
>> year. It took How long did it take
>> What case of harassment did they have?
What, the CPS call? Name one.
>> Hasan's audience to flip on Ethan? It
was very shortly after October 7th. Very
shortly.
>> What did he say very shortly after
October 7th? Oh, yeah, that's right.
Saying free Palestine is equivalent to
saying that you love Hamas and you
should have your family shot here.
>> Cuz Ethan was saying, you know, holy
[__] some of the commentary I'm seeing
from people is crazy. There were people
that were glorifying the violence on
October 7th.
>> So, right, what does Ethan say as
glorifying the violence? We're just
going to pull up the Kayla video. I'm
just going to play the clip just to make
the point once because it really is
crazy, the rewriting of history these
[__] zogbots trying to do for Ethan.
>> creators
>> Total [__] golem.
>> or how multicultural how [__] free
Palestine too closely to October 7th.
>> When you come out and say free Palestine
after they just lost everybody, that's
not what you should be saying right now.
>> And I'm free Palestine, too, right?
[music] It's just the timing. I know
what it is. You're saying I support
Hamas. I mean, that's what you're That's
what you're saying. I'm just saying
[music] don't cheer for terrorists. I
don't think that that's a crazy take. If
you think it is, then let's go invite
the Iraqi terrorists [music] who are
exacting revenge to come to your city
block and kill every [__] one you
love. If [music] you think Hamas is
dope, just remember you deserve to be
burned alive by terrorists
>> [music]
>> and your whole family murdered in front
of you.
>> Ethan's all
>> There were people that were pushing all
kinds of insane conspiracy theories,
accusing the Israeli government of
invoking like the Hannibal Directive,
and like there were people at the time,
I spoke with one of them on my stream.
He He jumped in my Discord, and we
talked about it.
>> Well, the if there's some crazy lefties
online, then it makes total sense why
Ethan completely cowed out and broke his
principles.
>> This was like the fringe fringe, like
really deep deeply online people that
were saying that it was like an IDF
Apache helicopter that killed all those
people at the rave. Like it just doesn't
make It doesn't make any [__] sense.
There was some unhinged [__] that that
like commentary takes that occurred like
right after October 7th. And um some of
it was popping up in like Hasan's
community, his Discord in particular,
that had to get nuked, as I understand
it, because there were some
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
>> crazy uh rhetoric that was going on.
ZJM, thank you so much for five gifted
memberships. Appreciate that. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, like the CPS thing, that was not
like the beginning. That was not what
started this whole thing. Do you not
remember they like
somebody made
>> According to Haaretz journalist Josh
Breiner, a police source said that a
police investigation indicated an IDF
helicopter, which had fired on Hamas
militants, apparently also hit some
festival participants. The statement by
Israeli police said their investigation
focused on police activity and not IDF
activity, and the statements in the
Haaretz article had been used out of
context on social media to blame Israel
for the deaths, none of which had any
basis in fact. In September 20 24,
Australia's ABC News followed up on
Yaniv Kubovics Kubovich's July 7th
article in Haaretz that the Hannibal
Directive was apparently applied with
panicked air crews firing on vehicles
containing hostages. ABC News asked the
IDF about the issue, and the IDF did not
answer ABC's questions, saying that
questions of this kind will be looked
into at a later stage. In the aftermath
of the attack, a widely disseminated
video purported to show leaked footage
of an IDF helicopter shooting at
civilians during the Reim Festival.
However, according to France 24, the
footage was actually part of a
compilation showing Israeli attacks on
the Gaza Strip October 9th. So,
disputed. It's not a conspiracy theory,
it's actually reported by Haaretz, but
it's disputed.
>> made an animated cartoon of Ela
murdering Palestinian kids. It was
[__] insane. Like it was actually
[__] insane. It was so foul. And
people spun her story of like going on a
ride-along in I don't even remember what
the city was, Ramallah? They were
calling her the butcher of Ramallah.
>> Raider of Ramallah.
>> Because she was like a bored [__]
18-year-old that went on a ride-along.
>> Wow.
>> So, who cares then?
>> Which she was clearly disturbed by.
>> Not true.
>> came up with all these insane narratives
>> False.
Obviously false. Just go watch the clip.
Just go watch the clip. It's just
obviously false.
>> It's meant That would have driven That
would have driven me insane. Like I
would I might have wanted to
>> That's all it takes.
>> fight back if I had been subjected to
that. I'm like 1/100 the size of Ethan,
and if I if I imagine the level of
[__] harassment
>> Why have they linked their careers to
Israel? They took a firm stance super
early on and can't walk back off of it.
Um they thought I think the calculation
was basically the
um
they thought Israel was just going to
steamroll everything and get out. And so
they'd never have to reconcile with the
fact that um a lot of people don't want
them to be Zionists and they could just
push through without getting criticism
or introspection on that.
>> It's meant that he was getting at the
time. I might want to do some drastic
measures. Wouldn't you? It's all It's
all very um
you know, pretty intense. Pretty [__]
intense. Dude, the post-October 7th
online climate was just so [__]
intense, man.
Uh Uh, I'm going to go to the bathroom
real quick. Give me just a minute. I'll
be right back, okay? Love you guys. I'll
be right back. I'll Out of matter of
like, you know, necessarily
I don't think I'm fighting the
as a member of the resistance or any
kind of [__] like that, but it's just
you
for for lack of other vent valves,
[__] with someone that's accessible
that has an audience that you think is
politically harmful.
>> There's another vent valve.
>> that work on these sons of [__] and
there was a just someone claiming Ethan
is going after pro-Palestine creators is
already bald faith, bad faith.
Ethan is pro-Palestinian. He just
doesn't think Israelis would let the
country be dissolved.
>> Right. Cool.
>> Um, thank you for the $10. All elite
memes with the tier
one membership for 7 months. They They
frame Ethan as ontologically evil to
justify it 100,000%.
>> [laughter]
>> Tim the Blair with the tier one I see
bald faith so often in my chat that my
brain turned it into that. Tim the
Blair, thank you so much for the tier
one membership. Appreciate that.
Super duper scooper with $10. Not saying
it's impossible for a Jewish kid to be
sheltered from Arab argument, but it's a
minority. American Jews overwhelmingly
are Dems. Israeli Jews are
overwhelmingly exposed to Arab argument.
Well, listen, I wasn't meant I wasn't
trying to say that it's like an
absolutist thing. Like no Jewish person
is ever taught about any part of like
the Arab perspective. That's certainly
not what I was saying, but if you're
raised Jewish, then you're there's a
very decent chance just like if you're
raised Catholic or if you're raised
Buddhist, there's a very decent chance
that you're going to have a very like
one-sided perspective of things as a
child. And then you get older and you
learn different perspectives and that's
just like a normal part of
growing up.
Um, yeah. Anyways, I don't want to
[__] I feel I feel like we're going
down a road here where we're like
relitigating like the the the post
October 7th
climate and I definitely do not want to
I'd rather not do that.
>> Cuz you're wrong about it.
Cuz you're wrong about this [__]
>> Months. [__] arguing about this and
that and this and that and this and
that.
>> It's not true. That's a lie. Dude, he
legit spends like 4 hours watching Hasan
in the stream, bro. People do have
influence and it's obvious they do. You
will hear the Oreo viewers say things
like, "Dude, nothing has made me hate
the pro-Palestine cause more than more
than seeing Nick cover Casey
They say that. They say that. You can
find Reddit comments saying that. You
can find YouTube video comments saying
that. Because that is the purpose of the
content. Whether Nick wants to
consciously accept it or not, that is
the purpose of the content. It is to
absolve Ethan and by extension
absolve Israel. And that's why there's
so many interest
>> Oh my god, you guys. God damn it. It's
so [__] demented.
>> Then
then
why are you not challenging it? Why are
you not challenging it? Hutch, don't you
think if I'm saying such insane stuff,
don't you think there's a pretty bad
pushback? Should you be
responsible platforming for my Nazi
ideas, Hutch? For my
Hitler speech? Why the ADL latches onto
his campaigns. That's why Dan works with
the ADL.
>> [sighs]
>> That is how it functions. So, there
really is quite a lot when you're, you
know, when you are post post posting
like hell, there really is quite a lot
against you, okay? You are actually
going up against quite a
>> Israel.
>> [laughter]
>> No, there's no one he's going up against
like Israel and Israel lobby.
>> No, you're going up against Dan,
Destiny, Ethan, sometimes the Oreo, but
they play into
the Israel lobby and benefit from it and
that strengthens them. That's cuz Dan is
writing for the free press and then
talks with the ADL and Ritchie Torres
and other congressmen and senators,
lobbyists. And they use that
international style up machine.
>> I had no idea. I I knew he was like a
little bit unhinged.
>> Is it
You wouldn't You wouldn't describe the
ADL as and the Israel lobby as an
international style up machine? What
else is it, Hutch?
>> I didn't know it was like this. I've
never seen any clips of him
talking like this. So, we see this is
anti-Semitic, right? Those are like
>> Dude. So, no rebuttal, just you're
unhinged, you're anti-Semitic, you're a
Nazi,
you love Hitler,
but not a single counterpoint.
>> [snorts]
>> I don't know how you could avoid those
vibes. I don't know how you could avoid
like the just blatantly anti-Semitic
vibes.
>> It's beyond parody, man.
I'm so glad this retard's doing
>> It's like so zog-brained, but
>> A lie, man. It's a lie, zog-brained.
>> a little bit like more advanced than
just like cuz zog is a little more kind
of um I guess like subtle. Like the zog
stuff is a little bit more subtle than
just like
going full Kanye, for example, but
>> This is full Kanye?
This is Defcon 3 on Jewish people?
>> It's like very just it feels like very
explicitly anti-Semitic.
>> And Stahli I spoke to Stahli the other
day. Stahli's got some crazy claims he
makes about this stuff. This was said in
the public VC, so I'll just share it
now. Stahli literally claims This is
what Stahli claims. Stahli claims, no
joke, that FBI agents or government
agents contacted him through family
members to inquire why he was deleting
so many negative posts about Casey Tron
and Denims. Now, I don't know that I
believe that. I don't know that I
believe that.
>> Why the [__] would you mention it then?
>> I I go the full way. I would need to see
a bit more. I would need to see a way
more. You know? I would never I
explained that in a moment, Archon. It's
because as much as I don't believe the
explicit claim, it's within the realm of
possibility because I see how it's being
used. stake anything on that. I would
literally never stake anything on that.
Don't get too excited by that cuz I Ooh,
there's a new Lanterns teaser. I'm
excited about that show.
>> [snorts]
>> Oh, yeah. I'm Zog-brained though, guys.
I'm the Zog-brained one. Right. I would
literally never stake anything on that.
Ever. Ever. You know? That that sounds
crazy. That sounds crazy. However, the
point that's being made there Yeah, he's
just asking questions. Yes. in that
story
is true. The point is true. Bro, they
actually they actually think I'm
throwing up Romans dog. They actually
they actually think I'm throwing up
Romans. But he showed with $10 the truth
of the matter is the smarter people are
losing their minds because what they
have been doing is coming out according
to Destiny more will come can't hide in
secret discords anymore. Again, I just I
don't have any just to be clear, I don't
have any advanced knowledge
about what is going to happen.
So, just to clear that up, but these
logs are out there. If I got my hands on
them,
I'm you know, I'm like a what? Like a
I'm like a small to mid to mid-size The
fact that everyone has this just shows
how little there is in there, man.
I'm on the spectrum between small and
mid-size streamer. Um and if I got my
hands on them, I assume like the full
logs at some point are going to go up on
the internet. Uh
and what it reveals is just a level of
just like obsession and kind of like
it's just a really kind of like pathetic
obsession and you know, routine it
doesn't reveal like docxing or IRA
harassment, swatting, any of those
claims that Destiny's made about us like
last year. Okay. inly coordinated
brigading, harassment campaigns, and you
know, like boosting each other's posts
online and giving each other
I didn't even tell you
>> This is only me by the way. Literally
it's just about poisoning the effective
strategy. It's just about crying that
other people are like playing the game
basically.
>> been finding this until like a couple
days ago, but like they were gassing up
the demon ogre boy going into the the
debate on live and learn.
Like they were treating ogre boy like he
was like their champion. Like it was
like and then that just went so bad for
them in my opinion. Like that was one of
the most embarrassing
>> debates [clears throat] Anyone that was
betting on Vadim, you know, I love Vadim
but
yeah.
>> of like the whole thing was so stupid.
Like you know, Vadim would lose
composure and just start screaming and
yelling and then when I would press him
he would be like um I'm going to let
ogre boy jump in here. It was so
embarrassing the whole thing. And just
to be fair, I just want to be fair here.
Actually, you know what? I want to
I want to clear a couple things up,
okay?
Vadim was not at all active in the
discord. I just want to say that just to
be fair to Vadim. Like I think he spoke
spoke up like one time and he wasn't
like using slurs or participating in
like target targeted brigading or
anything like that.
>> But Hutch if there's 10 Nazis at a table
and you sit down at the
>> Ogre boy on the other hand very active.
>> W ogre boy
>> very like up singularly obsessed with
me.
Which is not at all surprising. Um
>> [laughter]
>> W ogre boy
>> want to clear up Pisco was not in this
discord. There's no evidence that I
could find
any kind of like coordinating with
Pisco.
I see a lot like
>> That's true.
>> A lot of people have strong opinions
about Pisco.
>> Standing up for his friend for once, is
that crazy?
>> That's fine, but I'm seeing like
comments on like some of my videos that
I'm posting.
People are tagging me in tweets. They're
like, "Someone's got to press Pisco on
this. Someone's got to confront Pisco on
this." Pisco [__] There's no evidence
that Pisco
>> Well, why are people saying that Hutch?
Why are people saying that Hutch? Is it
because Destiny's deliberately attempted
to loop him into this whole narrative
since the moment you started breaking
away?
>> I hadn't anything to do with this. So,
just chill on that stuff. I don't know
why people need to jump to these kinds
of con- conclusions.
>> Where are those conclusions coming from
Hutch?
>> have a friends of the stream policy in
both chats. I feel like I need to remind
people. Maybe I need to add some
some more like mods on on YouTube. We're
a little bit better about policing it on
Twitch. It's a slower chat. There's more
mods.
Um
What mods are in the YouTube J? Do you
Do you have any more nominations for
mods in YouTube? It's fine if you like
It's fine if you really attack Pisco's
arguments. You know, some light some
light kind of teasing is fine, you know,
like I'm not going to get pissed if I
see people kind of making fun of me in
his chat. With the the stuff in his chat
that was like bothering me was people
were saying like the most unhinged
things and it had to do with like
Israel. People were accusing me of being
like a genocide supporter and [__] like
that. I don't care if people like tease
me in his chat or whatever. That's fine.
But, people need to chill the [__] out a
little bit
cuz there's just there's no there's no
evidence that I'm aware of. There's no
evidence that Pisco was at in any way
involved with the with the Discord. Dane
D with 133 months. Thank you so much.
Appreciate it. Oh my goodness.
>> raise massive interest from these huge
powerful bodies across the world in how
these issues are presented on the
internet.
>> My dude,
and I'm not throwing shade, okay? Cuz
I'm not It's not like my collective
audience is like enormously bigger than
his, you know? But my dude, do you
really think that the like secret Israel
lobby
>> Well, that's actually exactly what I
said, isn't it?
You guys hear that coming out of my
mouth where I said the the Israeli lobby
is targeting me specifically? I heard
that just now in that clip.
>> secret cabal, secret Israel cabal, the
secret international Israel lobby cabal.
Do you really think they're coming down
on you right now, Co-E-Man?
>> Yeah, that's what I said.
>> [__] commentary?
>> That's what I said, bro. That's what I
said.
>> Do you Do you have such an inflated
sense of self and importance that you
think that they would spend [__]
resources on you and your [__]
snarker buddies?
>> How does he argue against the ADL being
an influential psyop? Uh he doesn't. He
just goes, "You're an anti-Semite." and
moves on. Calls Calls you an anti-Semite
and looks at you like this. Or has a
face like this. He actually doesn't even
try to argue anymore. He just calls you
a Nazi and looks at you like this.
>> Do you really think that?
>> That is a huge incentive for, say, the
ADL to run a psyop campaign on Reddit,
to run a psyop campaign on Twitter. That
is
>> If it's a psyop campaign, then what does
it have to do with like Ethan Klein and
Destiny
covering up his sex crimes?
>> What?
Hasan, you've got like severe brain
damage from years of substance abuse.
However, if you listened just just a
moment ago, Hasan, you would have heard
that I was a bit defiant of the fact
that much of this slop content, like the
massive attention on Hasan, Casey,
Trondellem, and Fergan, actually does
influence people's positions on Israel.
>> Is it just like a convenient overlap?
Was the overlap intentional? It's like a
>> even Is that even what he's trying to
say there?
>> international psyop. They've got sleeper
agents in the in the Reddit running
counterintelligence
on the snarker community.
>> they they almost definitely do pay
people to post on Reddit. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But also it's about like destiny you
know it's like
I'll delete memes with $5. It took years
for people to even acknowledge
cyberbullying is real. Now kids use AI
for it too. I think government
regulation of snark is possible. But we
already have laws against like online
harassment, don't we?
Or do we? I don't even know. Arden pit
with $2 he didn't speak up much because
he was too sleepy.
Man, [snorts] that that Vadim Ogre Boy
live and learn episode was one of the
most that was the most shameful episode
we've ever done. I needed to take a
[__] shower after that episode.
Nobody chef for $10 the truth of the
matter is the snarker people are losing
their minds because what they Oh, I
think I already read that. Thank you,
buddy.
>> Is the reason I I believe even
explicitly that the Allisons bought
TikTok.
>> Did I get Facebook to you guys? I'm
going to
Here's a complete non sequitur.
So I'm scrolling through YouTube and
Twitter and I see
a video of
>> [clears throat]
>> it looked like
an indigenous person in Africa scrubbing
their teeth with
>> logs
>> some kind of root or something like that
and then the then the they they smiled
and their teeth were hell of [__]
white. I don't know did I get scyop
scyop? It's this thing called like mis
misla misra misla. Apparently like the
prophet Muhammad wrote about how you
need to clean your teeth with this like
particular root like five times a day or
something like that. Mis mis goes that's
what it's called. Mis miswak miswak.
[__] bought it, bro. I bought it. The
WHO
recognizes this
as being like just as effective as
toothbrushes. And for someone who's kind
of ADD kind of appeals to me cuz you're
just supposed to like use it. You just
like scrub your teeth with it. It's a
little hard to get the backside of your
teeth. And you don't even you don't even
you can you can just and and then you
scrub your tongue.
>> Okay.
>> And it helps with bad breath. There's
like chemical compounds in the root
itself. It like helps with bad breath.
It's like better at whitening your
teeth.
>> Thank you for the raid, Malcolm. Thank
you for the raid. Welcome in. Welcome
in. Welcome in.
>> I don't know.
>> Okay. I don't know. I don't know.
>> of dudes with mustaches, but I don't see
Hassan.
>> The face
>> Uh rate is what?
>> With $10, this is what I love about
Hutch. Alamillo.
>> Apparently this this miswak, is what you
call it, is like very good at cleaning
your teeth.
>> It's because of the anti-semitism on
there.
>> Um any personal favorite of yours for
the Dem presidential primary?
>> You will be investing in strategic
wiping strategies.
>> I don't care. I I like Kamala. I don't
give a [__] I'll say it.
I'll say it loud and proud.
>> I want to lose again.
>> of a comeback story.
>> I want to lose again. I'm desperate to
lose again.
>> revenge. Um and I do like her. Like I
genuinely like Kamala as a politician.
>> I [__] love losing. I want to lose.
[__] platinum. [__] them, Donnie. I want
to lose.
>> Like she's scrappy. She's [__]
scrappy. She's a fighter. And uh I You
know what I'm looking forward to? I'm
looking forward to seeing how she's
going to run her campaign when she has
like a full campaign to run. Like on her
terms, you know? I'm not saying I think
she has the best chance of winning.
Um I think right now we're in a massive
anti-establishment wave. Like more so
than 2016, I would say.
>> Yeah, if you're going to do this [__]
where you're like crying about the
populists, the least you could [__]
do
Yo, Must Guare with the 20 gifted.
Insanely [music]
generous of you, Must Guare. Hugely
appreciate. Thank you so much. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Hugely
generous of you. Thank you. Um
Yeah, if you're going to talk do this
whole thing where you're like crying
about the populists and saying that you
want the centrist candidate. At least
like talk about the policy. That's like
the one place
where oftentimes a a more centrist
establishment candidate will have a bit
of a edge over the populist cuz they
usually have a bit more of a defined
researched policy platform. Whereas
populist will often go for more
outlandish outsider ideas that try and
shake the system. Um so it the least you
can do if you're going to make a point
like this is to focus on policy
differences and focus on the policies
you like versus the other potential
candidates.
He didn't even do that. He's just like,
"I like I like Kamala. I like Kamala."
She's like, "Okay, well, that's [__]
worthless, isn't it, bro?" Cuz no one
else does.
>> And so that is going to be something
that might be difficult for her to
overcome because what's more
establishment than, you know, uh being
the vice president. Um
but I think it's possible. Like I think
that she she's scrappy enough to
uh
earn the respect of like Democratic
Party primary voters. Um but apart from
her, I don't know I'm not very picky,
man. I like I like the whole bench.
I'd be okay with like pretty much
everyone on the bench. Like, well, I'll
tell you like it
I don't party primary voters. Um but
earn the uh
earn the respect of like Democratic
Party primary voters. Um but apart from
her, I don't know I'm not very picky,
man. I like I like the whole bench.
I'd be okay with like pretty much
everyone on the bench. Like, well, I'll
tell you like it it pains me to say as a
native Californian, but my least
favorite, and I really hope he doesn't
win, is is Newsom. Not because I don't
like how scrappy he's been, not because
I don't like him as a governor, but I
just think he's going to have a tough
time in a national race. I think there's
a lot of baggage for someone like him,
viewed as uh he's kind of just like the
the person who is
>> muted? Was I muted [__] sake. I'm
[__] How long was I muted for
there?
>> [bell]
>> I'm [__] [__]
A couple minutes? Like one minute? Oh,
is that what it was? Just the last
pause? All I said was
Dickers basically stumped Hutch in a
course debate on Wix like 8 months ago.
Some [__] like that. And so I think
that's part of why Hutch has gone off to
Dickers in such a bizarre way.
And I think even like sort of [__]
tested Dickers afterwards to see if he
was able he was being bad faith. Did I
Did you Did my thanking of the gifter
come through? Or was I muted for that?
Surely not, right? Because huge
appreciation to Master Guerita for the
20 gifted which is insanely generous. It
It came through. Okay, good good. So I
wasn't muted for that long. All right,
sweet.
>> of
the liberal elites kind of caricature
that people have and I just don't know
how much appeal he has in states like
[__] Michigan and Pennsylvania. I'm
just concerned about that.
But pretty much everybody else, I'm
good. Yeah, if it's Kelly, I'm good with
that. I think Kelly's probably like on
paper the strongest candidate, you know,
this former astronaut, husband of a
congressperson who was shot in the
[__] face and survived,
has shown some real grit against Donald
Trump, was targeted by the Trump
administration. He checks off a lot of
bald. He would be our first like fully
bald king, I think ever. Eisenhower was
pretty bald, but I mean he's like bald.
Did Did Eisenhower shave his head? I
don't think he did.
Ossoff is just Ossoff is like a cheat
code. That guy is like a [__] cheat
code. He's really He's a really good
speaker. He is
like seems like decently popular in
Georgia, which is kind of a big deal.
He seems like he's going to somewhat
easily win his re-election campaign,
which that's a huge strength in a state
like Georgia. Uh you know, Warnock is
kind of he seems like interested in
running. I'd be good with him. He's a
good speaker, too. Um
Pritzker, I'd be happy with him. Yeah,
AOC, I'd be happy with
>> Politics stream with absolute zero
policy, just rambling about the
personalities. Very cool, watch. Very
cool.
>> her. I wouldn't even count AOC out. You
know, like I I think it's definitely
possible that the conditions could
create
>> Why do you have a muted moment almost
every stream? Because I roll cigarettes
close to my mic and I don't want the
sound of paper rustling coming through
on my microphone, so I mute frequently.
That's why. And I forget that I've
muted.
>> a path for her in 2028. Definitely
wouldn't count her out. There's not too
many people that I don't like. Like
Newsom is the only one that I just
wouldn't want. Like Newsom is the only
one where I'm like it shouldn't be him.
And then everybody else,
I'm good. And uh I don't think we have
to be picky.
>> Like I don't I don't take election
advice from the mentally challenged drug
addict that shoves sticks in his mouth.
>> Thank you.
>> think we need to worry as much about
electability in 2028 because things are
so bad for this Republican party that I
don't think it [__] matters. Like
honestly, I think Newsom would probably
win.
>> I think Newsom would probably beat
Vance, but it's so bad for Republicans
right now that [__] take your pick. I
think every every one of them smokes
Vance if the election was tomorrow. Who
are the other people on the uh like
Shapiro? I don't know. Shapiro is like
on paper really good, but he's almost
like too slick, you know what I mean?
But he's you know, he's a very popular
governor in Pennsylvania, so on paper
that's a big strength, but All Elite
Memes with $2 if Michelle Obama changes
her mind, she has a shot. She does not
want to be president. She has not been
shy about that. She does not want to be
president.
I think she would easily win if she ran,
but she does not want to be president.
>> Because that that
>> It's quite a jarring juxtaposition to go
from that conversation to this one, but
you know, I I think
I think Kamala, you know, I I think she
made a mistake by
prioritizing Biden's legacy. I also can
appreciate the fact that there probably
was always going to be limitations on
how much she could deviate from from
Biden, especially on Gaza, when the
current administration
that she serves under is actively
negotiating with Israel and like proxies
in Qatar for like a ceasefire. If she's
out there campaigning and and
criticizing Biden over Gaza and
criticizing Netanyahu, then that could
[__] those negotiations up. So, like
that's just she was in kind of like an
impossible situation to be fair to her.
I think she ran a good campaign,
definitely not a great campaign, and she
made some errors that I just don't know
if they would have made a difference,
but you know,
I like the idea of her
running another time and and then
running a second time and and well, I
guess this would be a third time, but
like on her terms, just fully unleashed.
And she's out here, guys, like talking
about major reforms. Kamala is out here
talking about major structural reforms.
Where's that clip of Kamala? She's
talking about packing the court, you
know, like she's she's out here like
[__] fired up, man. She's talking
about doing big stuff here.
>> Say, look, this is a moment where there
are no bad ideas. A no bad idea
brainstorm is what I'd like to call it.
And in that no bad ideas brainstorm, we
talk about what we need to do and think
about doing around the Electoral
College.
>> She's talking about maybe getting rid of
the [__] Electoral College, man.
>> We talk about the idea of Supreme
>> Does he move on here? No, he goes back.
Okay.
>> almost elated when she lost. You know,
people who are ostensibly opposed to
Trump, you know,
were like elated when she lost. In a
way, like nothing would make me happier
than to than to see her
to to to see her on a kind of redemption
arc, on a vindication arc. And to be
clear,
she specifically warned against like 20
things. She specifically warned She said
if Donald Trump wins, he's going to do
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and she was right
about [__] literally everything,
[__] everything. Everything. Like she
called like war with Iran,
wrecking the economy,
like irresponsible tariffs,
backing off of our commitments in
Taiwan,
uh
you know, unconstrained Netanyahu, like
like [__] 20 things and she called it
like
>> Wait, what's this? What's this? I've
been alerted to a huge Triton W here,
guys. One moment.
>> Yeah, so I understand the reasons.
However, what I do not understand is
Chud deciding to ban people who simply
point out this discrepancy. Enter the
prophet himself, surname
Triton.
>> That's Lord Triton to you, [__]
>> Okay.
Why was I removed from your server? I
just asked a simple question about Keem
and the double standard Washamoo. Chud
logic says, because you are a [__]
effer bothering me. Keemstar wasn't even
in my server, [__] [__] Get raped.
Can't take criticism?
>> [laughter]
>> It seems like you got raped because you
can't take a simple disagreement.
>> [laughter]
>> Make a video about it that no one will
watch.
I just gave criticism.
>> [snorts]
>> And then here's the one that
particularly stings. HAHA. OH,
[groaning] the Nikki D REFERENCE.
>> OH, THE NICKY D REFERENCE.
>> You're acting like Nicholas DeOrio right
now.
>> people [laughter] for criticism.
>> Banning people for criticism?
>> Oh, Chud, we've fallen so far. This is a
dark path. I thought you'd sw-
>> You're a waste of my time. [__] off. And
he keeps going going down and with
Triton and DMs, brother.
>> [laughter]
>> You're wasting my You're wasting my
[__] time. Make a video. And I'm
going to keep replying.
>> bored off long ago. You asked mad, dude.
The fact that Triton is having this
entire conversation with like a real
Visier [__] PFP with a smug
shit-eating grin.
He's so [__] [__]
>> Bunk is lost and floundering.
>> Thank you for the 499.
>> Akim comes home, okay?
>> Um uh is he in the hospital?
>> restored to his former glory and he says
Chud Logic has unbanned me and admitted
wrongdoing.
>> [laughter]
>> Officer Nasty says, "Link." And then
Triton leaks the DMs. Wait, no.
>> [laughter]
>> Wait, what did he link to him before?
What
>> [snorts]
>> He's linking the [__] Revenge of the
Sith.
[__]
You were my brother [__]
>> Did he link to him before? Dude, is that
the [__] You were the chosen one. You
were meant to destroy the Sith, not join
them. Okay, nice.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, man. I was annoyed earlier
The raped male returns. Hey, man. I was
annoyed earlier because you added me
with some sort of hypocrisy hunting when
I was in the middle of something. It was
excessive to ban you, though. You're
welcome to rejoin.
>> Chud says, "Hey, man.
I [laughter] was annoyed earlier because
you were added me with some some sort of
hypocrisy hunting when I was in the
middle of something. It was excessive to
ban you, though. You were welcome to
rejoin.
>> [laughter]
>> No more brother wars. Let's go. No more
brother wars. Let's go.
>> Child logic is on banned me and admitted
wrong doing.
>> Okay, fantastic.
>> Don't be trying me, honestly. Don't be
trying me.
>> Uh, Dar Savage, thank you so much for
$5. If people believe a lie, that's a
huge hurdle to get to cross their vote.
Average person isn't going to Google it.
Kamala's great, but many dislike her. I
just listen. You know, I would not count
her out. I mean, I think that's bold. I
think that's bold. I would not count her
out.
Um, she can overcome a lot. And I
honestly, like things are so bad for
Donald Trump and the Republican Party
that it changes a lot of the
calculation. You know,
uh, I think it makes it makes the
Democrats job so much easier to come
across as sympathetic, assertive,
strong. And you know, people like a good
comeback story. This is This is America,
you know, like Rocky and and whatnot,
etc., etc. Abracadabra, did I get you
for Did I I think I did. Jay with $5, I
nominate all elite memes for mod. I'll
shout out others as I see them in chat.
You just got to read chat today. I'm I'm
reading chat. I'm reading chat. All
elite memes?
>> Some of this is just trail and software.
Uh, that I
Those are like
to be s-
>> Okay, [__] this. We We're done with
that. [__] it, man. I I guess Is that
Let's try and see the last bit. They
start switching between me and Hasan.
>> He testing the
>> Zaug posting for a little bit and then I
want to cover Hasan purity testing the
absolute [__]
>> is
>> There's massive interest from these
huge, powerful bodies across the world
in how these issues are presented on the
internet. There is a huge incentive for,
say, the ADL.
>> Did you vote in that election for mayor?
>> He says he's not going to engage with
any of it, is he? I can't I'm just going
to [__] it. I don't know. I can't do
this.